microsoft is about to kill zuckerberg's
metaverse before it even launches and
they won't even need to build a vr
headset to do it now this probably
sounds crazy after all zuck is so
invested in the metaverse that he
renamed his entire company just to focus
on the effort and he's planning on
investing 180 billion dollars over the
next 10 years building this thing but
his plan is flawed for a few reasons at
first glance zuck looks well positioned
here billions of people use facebook
instagram and whatsapp every day to
connect with friends and family and he
also owns the biggest virtual reality
company even though vr is still seen as
a toy to most people the quest actually
outsold the xbox in 2021 but even though
there are plenty of signs that zuck will
be able to deliver microsoft isn't just
going to let him win there are three key
reasons why microsoft will beat
zuckerberg in the war for the metaverse
so let's go through them one at a time
we are creating an entirely new platform
layer which is the matterhorse
we're bringing people places and things
together with the digital world
my two previous videos on the metaverse
got absolutely flooded with comments
asking isn't the metaverse just a video
game we already have those these people
would point to second life world of
warcraft and fortnite to make the point
that we kind of already have a metaverse
and these people aren't wrong gaming is
a great entry point into the metaverse
but in the long term things are going to
get a lot crazier these metaverse
experiences are going to become bigger
and more immersive with the ability to
interact with millions of people all in
a single shared virtual world digital
assets and avatars will move between
different spaces and full economies will
emerge to support a wide range of
contributors we don't know exactly what
platform will be the most dominant yet
but one thing is for sure gaming is
going to play a huge role here and
that's why microsoft's strategy is so
genius they've been a massive player in
the video game industry for decades now
first with pc games like doom in the 90s
and later with xbox games like gears of
war facebook on the other hand only
really gave us farmville and not many
people would call that one a classic
building a platform for amazing games is
one thing but microsoft can't do much
with them if they don't actually own the
studios that create them so microsoft
has been growing a gaming empire for
years and it's about to get a lot bigger
in 2014 microsoft bought minecraft for
2.5 billion dollars the game has grown
to over 140 million monthly active users
and is quickly morphing into its own
mini metaverse and now players are
building entire simulations like this mr
beast competition with 2 000
simultaneous contestants then in 2020
microsoft bought zenimax media for 7.5
billion dollars which gave them the
rights to fallout doom and the elder
scrolls they're finally awake all of
these games have communities of modders
that are changing and growing the
experience and now most recently
microsoft acquired activision blizzard
for 69 billion dollars that's an
absolutely massive amount of money but
microsoft has 130 billion dollars in
cash laying around and this is going to
be really important for their metaverse
strategy this acquisition has drawn a
lot of attention though and i think most
people are misunderstanding what's
really going on here activision owns
some of the biggest gaming franchises in
the world games like call of duty
overwatch and even tony hawk these games
are cross-platform and widely available
on playstation and nintendo consoles but
will they stay that way if you spent 69
billion dollars on this game studio yeah
i'd say you make some of those a little
exclusive to your platform and take
advantage of that and sure this sounds
like a smart business move for microsoft
take call of duty away from playstation
and more people will buy xboxes but
that's actually not their strategy see
back in 2017 microsoft launched the xbox
game pass which offered access to a huge
library of microsoft games all for a
single monthly fee it was basically the
netflix model but it marked a very
significant shift in their business
strategy before game pass if microsoft
bought a game studio and then made those
titles exclusive to xbox sales would
instantly start dropping sure maybe some
gamers would switch from playstation to
xbox during the next upgrade cycle but
in general these acquisitions would be
value destructive but now microsoft can
continue to sell games for full price on
other consoles while offering these
games as part of the xbox game pass
bundle
buying activision makes xbox game pass
more enticing and sticky since gamers
will now get all that content for free
as long as they are subscribed the
second issue people get wrong about the
activision acquisition is the idea that
this will create a gaming monopoly even
though this is a huge acquisition the
game publishing market is still
remarkably fragmented just look at this
chart of game publishers by revenue even
after combining microsoft and activision
sony and tencent will still be larger
new breakout successes happen every year
in the gaming industry so no one has
complete control at least not yet
compare that chart to the market for
search engines and you'll see what i
mean
clearly google has a monopoly on search
no other companies stand a chance
against them but of all the game
publishers that microsoft is competing
against facebook and meta aren't even
listed that's because zuck has only
built out a few small gaming initiatives
for vr and has yet to acquire any of the
big gaming companies it could be that he
just doesn't believe that the
traditional gaming franchises will adapt
to the metaverse and this is honestly an
open question in my mind is the
metaverse more likely to grow out of
overwatch or some other familiar game or
will these metaverse experiences be
built around new intellectual property
either way if the metaverse ultimately
evolves from the gaming industry zuck is
going to be in big trouble people might
be using quest headsets to access the
metaverse and enjoy vr experiences but
microsoft will have a massive advantage
in terms of actually defining how users
interact with the metaverse there is
another path to the metaverse though and
it's useful here to look at how personal
computers wound up in every household
everyone wants a computer in their house
these days but back when they were first
released to the public most consumers
had no interest in them these big bulky
machines were basically glorified
calculators so most people had no use
for them in their homes but pretty
quickly they became indispensable at
work companies bought their employees
computers because it increased
productivity all of a sudden employees
didn't need to spend hours shuffling
paperwork and could instead store
information in computers that meant
increased profits so every company
rolled them out the interesting thing
was that once people got used to using
computers at work they wanted to use
them at home too as the number of home
computers increased so did the demand
for non-work applications like games you
might have bought a home computer to
type up letters but pretty quickly you'd
want a game on that thing it's possible
that the metaverse will follow a similar
path first your company buys you a
virtual reality headset so you can
collaborate remotely with everyone
working remotely spending a few hundred
bucks is totally worth it if it can
improve productivity even a little bit
heck i could even see companies sending
everyone a vr headset just for a holiday
party it's not uncommon for tech
companies to spend thousands of dollars
on corporate events so a few hundred
bucks per employee seems doable
zuckerberg is clearly bought into this
vision and wants to make horizon
workrooms the default application for
virtual work but can he beat microsoft
here fundamentally it's very difficult
for companies to switch their focus from
consumers to businesses for better or
worse people just associate meta with
their crazy uncle who posts unhinged
rants on facebook every day now to be
fair facebook launched workplace back in
2016 so they aren't completely new to
the industry but microsoft has been
selling software to companies since the
1970s it's just a completely different
level of experience here and even though
microsoft is still closely associated
with the windows desktop operating
system satya nadella has essentially
pivoted microsoft away from a focus on
windows and fully embrace the cloud
microsoft understands that very few
companies will exclusively stick to
using pcs with windows on them tons of
people want to use apple products and
many developers insist on running linux
this device fragmentation was going to
limit the success of any microsoft
product that required windows to run so
they built teams most people think of
teams as just a slack ripoff and clearly
some of the design elements are the same
but microsoft is planning something much
bigger with teams it starts with
document sharing and video chat
basically all the normal business stuff
and then slowly grows into the deeper
metaverse concepts zuck is always
talking about and i get it the
enterprise collaboration side of things
sounds way more boring than the video
game side but it really is critical to
microsoft's metaverse strategy if you
think about a metaverse as a sort of
mirror world where you can interact with
data and applications in a more
immersive way microsoft might honestly
get there first for starters microsoft
already has a suite of products that let
companies create what are called digital
twins these are basically virtual
representations of physical objects like
manufacturing equipment but it's not
enough to just have a 3d model of a
factory companies want to know what each
piece of equipment is doing how much
energy the plant is using and when the
latest batch of products will come off
the line this is all part of the
internet of things that was very trendy
a few years ago but never quite found a
foothold with the everyday consumer
aside from maybe a smart thermostat here
or there but in a business context these
metaverse concepts can prove remarkably
useful once real-time factory data is
syncing with the digital twin companies
can start analyzing performance metrics
and even build automated systems to
further increase efficiency where this
gets interesting is when employees go
and actually see the digital twin data
while walking around the physical world
this is made possible by augmented
reality like microsoft hololens although
interestingly microsoft isn't
particularly tied to that particular
piece of hardware as i mentioned before
microsoft is moving away from a single
computing platform and wants to work
everywhere that's why you can use teams
to chat with co-workers on a macbook and
you can also stream gears of war to your
iphone microsoft isn't interested in
locking you into a piece of hardware and
that's going to be a big advantage going
forward so microsoft is basically
attacking zuckerberg on two fronts
they've got an excellent foothold with
business users and they're building a
massive empire over in gaming zuck is
getting really beat up right now but he
seems to be doubling down anyway so
let's find out why predicting the future
is hard really hard if you can do it
well you'll quickly become massively
wealthy there's a problem though
sometimes you can see the future clearly
and still not be able to execute a
winning strategy that's what happened to
bill gates nearly three decades ago the
year was 1995 and bill gates was riding
high everyone was buying pcs windows was
revolutionizing workplaces and microsoft
was on track to become the most valuable
company in the world so bill stood on
stage and mapped out what he thought
would come next this industry will be at
the center of all of it with its
software innovation its competitive
hardware will be shaping this so-called
information highway he was talking about
the internet and even though we quickly
stopped using the phrase information
highway to describe it bill nailed a few
key predictions now we call it the
wallet pc because it's capable of really
replacing everything that you carry with
you so that getting messages uh seeing
the latest news seeing a different
location keeping track of your schedule
that sounds an awful lot like a
smartphone to me and bill didn't stop
there he also explained how cars would
have large displays with real-time maps
how customers would purchase things with
their phones and how homes would have
smart controls these predictions
basically all came true but oddly enough
not because of microsoft even though
bill explained exactly how a smartphone
should work microsoft has never been
able to gain market share against apple
and google and the same is true for maps
payments and even the smart home google
and apple are dominant in those areas
with microsoft usually a distant third
so what does this mean for zuckerberg
and his plans to build the metaverse
well that bill gates presentation shows
that even when your predictions about
the future are correct it doesn't
necessarily mean that you'll win it's
entirely possible that everything zuck
has laid out will come true we'll all be
wearing vr headsets and interfacing in
virtual worlds but meta could wind up
having nothing to do with it microsoft
missed the mobile internet revolution
because they were too focused on the
windows operating system once satya
nadella decoupled microsoft from windows
the company could become more agile and
could really start competing in new
industries there's still one question
though when will the metaverse actually
arrive in order to answer that question
just watch this video next thanks a lot